i've been creating some controversy
during a town hall last night
biden taking heat over this claim about
the trump administration and the vaccine
the biggest thing though is you remember
when you and i i shouldn't say it that
way as you remember but
when you and i talked last we talked
about it's one thing that the vaccine
which we didn't have when we came into
office
but a vaccinator how do you get the
vaccine into someone's arm
so you need the paraffin they need the
needle you need the mechanisms to be
able to get it in you have to have
people who
can inject it in people's lives
the president also contradicting his
press secretary on reopening schools
biden saying gensake made a quote
mistake
when she said the goal is to have
schools open one day a week
in his first 100 days dana i think that
the biggest controversy is about what he
said regarding the vaccine in the trump
administration he seems to say that
trump left no stockpile of vaccine
and no federal strategy for distributing
the vaccine is that right
well it's simply not true and we can we
know that because we were reporting on
the vaccines that were being
administered in late december all the
way through
until the inauguration including i
believe joe biden himself got a vaccine
at that
during that time in addition in the
morning and this is quite common after
you have an event like
the town hall last night you send out
lots of different people from your
administration's team
to blanket the airwaves to try to keep
the good times going but i think they
had a pretty hard time today
vice president kamala harris on the
today show got caught up in
a whirlwind of non-answers when it came
to school closures and reopenings
and then i think even simone sanders on
cnn
a similar thing and why is that well
in my experience it means that you don't
have good facts
communications is easy when the facts
are correct
and when you're trying to like skirt
things around and talk about cdc
guidance maybe change maybe didn't
i think they're in for a little bit of a
rough patch i know that everyone
in the country seemed to be like taking
a breather after inauguration
but all of a sudden now the biden team
is now going to be judged on things
that are going to be slightly out of
their control but they're making some
promises
on kovid that they might not be able to
fulfill but also
they're asking the country and the
taxpayers to spend a heck of a lot of
money
a lot of money and we should dig into
that a little bit more for what that
money is going to go for for covet
relief
when the economy continues to do fairly
well so that
i think everyone can agree very targeted
relief for the people that need it
restaurant owners service industry
people you know the single moms that are
out there that
had to leave their jobs so that they
could be at home with their kids because
they're on zoom all day trying to do
classes i think that this bill is going
to be very very expensive
and that after this period of everybody
taking a little bit of a breather
i think the biden team is about to have
a little bit of an awakening
in the next couple of weeks
katie today the president announced a
billion dollar spending on the virus
testing
and expanding testing to help open the
k-8 schools and deal with
the spread of the virus in homeless
shelters and increase
the supply of vaccine because a lot of
people still complain they can't get it
what's your reaction
well uh joe biden was elected and
because he argued on the campaign trail
that he was the guy who knew washington
that he would be
he would be capable of doing a better
job of dealing with the pandemic than
president trump and his administration
was able to and because they didn't give
operation warp speed the credit that it
deserves
now they're in this place where people
are saying well you said you were going
to be better than the trump
administration when they were
decently good given that they got a
vaccine in under a year which is a
miracle
and had distribution set up with ups and
fedex and the military was involved
but now the biden team is trying to
lower expectations they've been doing it
since they came into office
and now they're lying about the idea
that there was no vaccine
there was a vaccine there are multiple
vaccines there are still vaccines that
are waiting for fda approval to go out
now is this a tough thing to deal with
sure is there a prioritization process
that needs to be involved
yes especially when you have teachers
unions for example trying to
jump in front of the line of vulnerable
seniors and other people who should get
the vaccine first
and then the politics get involved and
so you know joe biden promised a lot
on covet and so far they aren't
delivering it when they promise to
follow the science to get kids back in
school
and to deal with this in a better way
than trump did and so far they are
far below what the trump administration
was able to do
well jesse to that point uh the trump
administration points out that the new
infection rate is down substantially
since inauguration day
uh and that you know biden has pushed
mass social distancing
increase the supply of the vaccine does
he deserve credit for that
um i'm not ready to give him credit
just yet juan that was a trend that he
took advantage of
i did watch this town hall last night
and it was lackluster
this guy is not a strong communicator
he struggles to complete sentences he
stops
and restarts and restarts back up again
sometimes meandering from one point to
the next
no idea where he's going really having a
hard time
a difficult time putting together
coherent
concise and persuasive thoughts maybe
once or twice an hour he'll manage a
very
powerful strong connection with the
audience or even i say yeah there you go
joe
but then the 90 of the time he goes back
to just
listlessly wandering around and not
keeping your attention and it makes you
realize
that this guy must need a lot of help to
just
perform the basic duties of being a
chief
executive he's out there bragging that
he ordered more doses for the vaccine
like
as if no other president would have
thought to do that
and then he's out there bragging that he
had a two-hour conversation with the
leader of china
as if that's something to be proud of
and if that's some
testimonial to how great he's able to
perform at a level
that's strong and and vibrant and then
he ends up
basically repeating chinese propaganda
and says that oh the chinese need to
crack down because
they're always being victimized by
foreign powers um
well uh joe china's always been
dominated by foreign powers and
that's actually the propaganda they use
to justify
their human rights abuses and crackdowns
i don't know why he said that jesse
well jesse let's take a look at that and
i'll get greg to respond
the central principle of xi jinping
is that there must be a united tightly
controlled
china and he uses his rationale for the
things he does based on that
i point out tim no american president
can be sustained as a president
if he doesn't reflect the values of the
united states and so the idea i'm not
going to speak out against
what he's doing in hong kong what he's
doing
with the uyghurs and western mountains
of
uh china and taiwan trying to end the
one china policy
by making it forceful i i said and by
the he
said he he gets it culturally there are
different
norms at each country and they their
leaders are expected to follow
greg your reaction uh i
what what he's doing with the uyghurs
somebody should have followed up and
asked him what is he doing with the
uyghurs
i guess joe is so woke he sees china's
treatment of the uyghurs as part of
their wonderful diversity
uh you know who are we to judge um you
know
he oddly presented a justification for
china putting people in actual
concentration camps and killing them
and just days ago i seem to remember joe
biden condemning
our administration previous
administration
of separating children from people who
claim to be their parents
uh putting them in cages and they and i
remember biden calling it immoral and
shameful
and then here this is actually
deliberate
and documented evil and it's like you
know we do things differently they do do
things differently you know blah blah
blah
i will add to this uh so that's garbage
it's garbage that's the worst thing
about it that's worse than his mistakes
he basically said it he basically gave
uh
gave china a pass but there's another
thing about his
uh answers the meandering answers he's
the benefit
of the medium meaning that in it that
the media
they don't have time to listen to
everything so they edit it for him
so whenever you see what he's going to
say you never see the whole thing
you see it all scrunched down to about
there because no
network has the time to play his like
his wilderness you know wandering you
know
uh confusion they have to which i just
did now but
so he actually benefits from it
all right coming